from Apple phones to Nintendo consoles
many of the products Americans love are
made in China but is that about to
change the country has long been the
world's manufacturing powerhouse because
it has the raw materials and chief
workers to power supply chains for years
companies especially tech giants like
apple and Dell have relied on Chinese
factories to assemble their products
because of the ongoing trade dispute
between the US and China and escalating
tariffs threat from the Trump
administration many manufacturers have
started to lay out plans to shift some
that production elsewhere in a recent
survey of 250 companies operating in
China 40 percent have said that they are
considering or have relocated
manufacturing facilities outside the
country analysts expect there could be
more if the trade dispute escalates here
are three cases that can tell us why
companies are looking to move out of
China first tariffs this is one of the
biggest concerns for any company that is
importing made in China products into
the u.s. in May the u.s. increased
import tires to 25 percent from 10
percent on two hundred billion dollars
of Chinese goods the Trump
administration is also planning to place
tariffs on an additional 300 billion
dollars of Chinese imports if this new
round of tariffs kicks in it would cover
electronics like smartphones laptops and
videogame consoles which are almost
entirely imported from China companies
like Nintendo want to limit the impact
of these u.s. tariffs on Chinese male
electronics for years the Japanese
company needed low contract
manufacturers in China to assemble its
video game hardware that's because video
game platform owners tend to sell
hardware at a thin profit so it's not
the console lip rings in the big box
it's the revenue from games if Nintendo
had to pay a 25% tariff to import its
Chinese made consoles into the US that
thin profit would be decimated so
Nintendo has said it's shifting
production to Southeast Asia to limit
that impact the company has started
producing the switch and two new models
there
companies are also realizing that they
can't put all their eggs in one basket
with a wing guerring trade dispute
between China and the US many companies
might also have to think about
diversified production locations one
example is Apple the company relies on
hundreds of thousands of workers and in
steep network of suppliers in China to
crank out iphones people familiar with
the matter said Apple is now asking
suppliers to consider shifting the final
assembly elsewhere the company declined
to comment luckily one of Apple's
contract manufacturers Foxconn says it's
ready to move the company says it has
about 25% of its manufacturing outside
the mainland and its factories around
the world can keep churning out
sufficient quantities of the Apple
products some companies are worried
about being swept up in the political
tit-for-tat between China and the US
case in point
Huawei the u.s. hit the Chinese telecom
giant with an export ban shortly after
trade talks collapsed last month which
barred many American companies and
Beyond from doing business with a
company China responded by saying it
will create its own list of foreign
entities seen as damaging to Chinese
companies and national interests
manufacturers are also worried about
increased roadblocks that Chinese
authorities may put up like increased
regulation customs delays or greater
scrutiny before negotiations collapsed
both countries were discussing ways to
make it easier for foreign companies to
invest and operate in China but now the
talks are at a stalemate Chinese
officials have warned there could be
consequences if companies move it's been
a long year of trade negotiations
between Washington and Beijing and a
deal likely won't come anytime soon
companies like Apple and Nintendo are
seeking out alternative locations for
production while other companies sit it
out hoping that a deal will come either
way it's expensive for companies
[Music]